thank you
[Music]
here's another uh thing for you guys to
solve easy dude
oh [__] that what it's already too hard
do Canada stuff I don't get it but
they're like the Frenchie Canadian
that's like typical clap so in Montreal
on an overpass somebody hung up three uh
dead pigs whoa the big bad wolf wait
were they already dead or they died
because of the hangings
that's not to be yeah they don't know
what was the point
why waste food yeah why why would
someone do that we pigs that sounds like
uh like an old school like gang name or
something like we're the three dead pigs
this is our symbol this is our territory
yeah you know who it is Batman nah man
is [__] the it is who's the guys that
don't like the Three Little Pigs the Big
Bad Wolf
full right
how do you do this earlier
wrong yeah I was thinking it was it was
yeah the grandma oh the grandma you know
the grandma that killed but that's the
biggest
that's amazing how you do that I'm
starting to get very impressed
who's the guy
riding hood trying to frame the big bad
wolf because the wolf [__] with her
she's like how I'm gonna put these three
pigs and make it look like you did it so
the one that was eating the oatmeal
they're like it's too hot Goldilocks
that's Goldilocks those are bearers the
Three Bears yeah maybe they did it
that's what I got it confused with the
three bears that get and then they're
like hey you wolf don't come to my house
and then the wolf is like it's straw and
then they're like
the house down and then the bears run
away and they're like we need to get a
[__] brick house dude I think we
cracked the case I think you're Crossing
DC it's a Multiverse now it's DC and
Marvel for sure
yeah so uh why would somebody do that
what do you think I'm trying to be
energy pigs like you're gonna be mad by
the way when I tell you why it is
um because it's activists activism
they're like hey come on we gotta save
the animals here's some three dead
animals to bring awareness to this no
that's absolutely what it was are you
[__] kidding wait wait can I say
something let's save the Animals by
killing the animals
I'm assuming they're already dead so in
their mind there's a logic to like all
right you want to eat these Frozen pigs
or whatever you know what I mean check
this out yeah but I still think it's a
terrible example it's an activism so
like let's let's save meat by wasting
meat whatever happened to the good
old-fashioned go to a museum get a can
of soup throw it on a paper now
glue the hand
those guys that is true bravery compared
to this that's this is hanging three
pigs that's cowardice what happened to
the good old-fashioned take the picks
the Filipino person's house take a big
hole crispy hot coals in there put the
pigs covering banana leaves yeah wait a
few hours Let's feed some folks yeah
that's cool but you know why also
because like what the best solution
right which is not to eat animals and
you become vegan but then when you
become vegan everybody's gonna make fun
of you exactly there's like no Solutions
hey the weird part is making sense
that's very true you're absolutely right
Ken so this is the weird thing like you
would think if you hang like an animal
like a dead animal and often overpass
yeah you should go to jail that's kind
of like sort of dishonoring the animal
in the way it just looks like Sam whoa
what do you mean disrespecting the [__]
out of the pig man but this is
it is really an action of denunciation
towards cruelties made to animals we
want it to be a clear message when
people pay to kill animals it comes with
a lot of unnecessary suffering that we
are able to avoid okay dude then you so
you make better slaughterhouses or
something I don't know you're trying to
show like hey this is graphic because if
Montreal has a lot of Asians they're
just going like oh my God it's like a
Chinese barbecue you know what they
should have done after they hung the
pigs take photos then take them off and
then cook them and then reuse the pig
photo you know and then put it on you
know how animal rights active yeah but
it's like if you're really trying to
save them that's what I would have done
it just reminds me of like back in the
90s there was a there was an activist
group called elf and they yeah they did
this thing where they they were
protesting the production of uh gas
vehicles so they went to a Hummer
dealership and they burned the entire
thing down every Hummer all the tires
and what happened what ended up
happening is they caused way more
pollution in that one act than any one
of those Hummers lifetime yeah from all
the tire burning the chemical but that
street cred though those idiots and then
they left graffiti that said if you was
it if you build it we will burn it
that's gangster and this was an
environmental activist group
that's why you gotta go back to the
[__] song why why do like
environmental activist groups like how
come they don't think things through
like oh they're so emotional why don't
they just go to the beach and pick up
trash the actual productive what the
[__] because they're not logic you know
what though is like they don't have jobs
hour like minute per minute you're
actually making a difference or you know
what I've seen one where um it was
actually in Waikiki where this guy had a
giant TV screen wrapped around his neck
and he was showing like like how like uh
farming animals was going down I was
like that's pretty effective like I
think you might get a couple people that
are like oh [__] because it is pretty
scary to see how they just makes me
hungry for some people you might get
that reaction but then you might sway
some other people are like oh my God
that's terrible that's horrendous yeah
we should uh try to stop this because I
think I feel like for for certain people
it's like that's that's the probably the
better way to do it this is just like
how I was gonna try to retaliate me
hanging three dead pancakes I'm like
take that dead I'm just gonna make those
guys hungry they just be like oh what
the why there's three [__] Belgian
waffles up there that make me hungry
they have to be still trying to process
live or dead pancakes
like if you hang my food I'll hang your
food how about that huh okay some tofu
box looking at three giant pigs and he's
like that's my food
how about your fingers
you know what sucks about these idiots
is like they get grouped in with other
sustainable scientists and people that
are just trying trying to do smart [__]
people are trying to build an
infrastructure for a better yeah because
then like some of these guys will leak
into politics too and then they'll do
stupid [__] like like we'll do a whole
plastic ban and I'm like I know Plastics
are [__] yeah it's destroying the
environment but we don't have a better
alternative so you can't just ban
something with a better alt without any
answers you can just be like stop doing
it it's like yeah well we don't want to
use it but then like harder than the guy
that invented plastic exactly so come up
with Alternatives and then so they're
trying to come out with plant-based
Plastics and like other kind of things
right but the issue is like if you don't
have enough time to test it there's a
lot of
um like other issues that come up yeah
exactly so like plant Plastics they
don't do good in heat so what's
happening is they smell like [__]
putting like hot drinks and then all the
thing is melting and it's causing more
contamination issues and like it's just
[__] it's just [__] bad those guys I
think we did a story where they built
these like drone ships to collect all
the trash in the ocean oh yeah in the
Pacific yeah that like how cool is that
that's right but what happened like
iteration like number two or number
three and they're like by this time
we're gonna be able to do this blah blah
it's like there's some goal orientation
to it well it's because they're smart
and they know how to deal with like how
do we problem solve versus The Angry
dumbasses out there that are like you
gas guzzling son of a [__] and then
they burn up a Hummer causing more
issues yeah yeah like that stupid ass 16
year old lady 16 that keeps complaining
about [__] uh [__] the ground
[__] Granite like oh she's overrated
global warming
snowed in La last
last week coolest it's ever been hey
that's small dick energy yeah dude you
idiot what do you mean I it [__]
snowed everywhere she's kind of annoying
I think it's more of a climate change
not much global warming yeah but isn't
climate change the whole things we're
getting warmer guys no no
[Laughter]
longer changed cold too
make up your mind
even that right so like all these
politicians and people like talking
about climate change and and like we
gotta [__] reduce the use of [__]
autos and all that but they're wasting
so much jet fuel in their private planes
to go to these conversations and all
that and it's like they're not being
environmentally friendly themselves and
all of these guys that are out here like
Al Gore whatever talking about oh the
[__] sea levels Rising be careful but
they all have beachfront properties yeah
so I'm like how are you gonna have a
[__] beach house and then talk talk
about you guys [__] be careful and
it's like I don't believe you anymore I
think that's maybe why why I I kind of
enjoy looking at Greta sometimes uh that
that little kid because she gets to be
like uh Angry Angry Child and say
certain things that like those older
people just won't yeah I think it's just
a a necessary voice in that space it's a
waste of air time I'd rather watch a
Tide commercial play double commercials
and don't let her speak how about that I
really do want obviously like I'm not a
gold navy break dancers I'm not against
I'm not against like healing people like
I like I don't think anyone here is
against like wanting a [__] up
environment right but I think that
there's so much damage being done by
hastily trying to create a solution
that's not even thoroughly like thought
out so then like that and then they're
shaming people without even like coming
up with a solution and I also think that
the whole environmental like activism
group I think they're extremely racist
and stupid and the reason why I say this
is because a lot of these like finger
pointing and all that it goes to
developing countries
all them who are producing a lot of
missions and all that right so to me
this is what I this is how I see it it's
like saying we had our time to develop
industrialized Industrial Revolution we
had you know we don't a manufacturer in
the US anymore because we just have them
do the dirty work right and then we're
pointing the finger at them and saying
like shame on you look at all this
[__] toxic waste you're creating and
then they're [__] doing it on their
iPhone that's creating all the [__]
yeah
yeah and insane with people that are
from poor countries that don't have much
of a food source right and you have all
these [__] vegans and militant Pita
people going like don't eat don't eat
the animal it's like they're hungry
[__] what the [__] are they gonna eat
it is elitist because it's like yeah you
have the luxury to have the option to
not do yeah they're the ones that could
go to [__] Irwin and Whole Foods and
be like [__] super organic and like
50 dollar shopping bags right and then
what about these poor ass people that
are like man I gotta eat a rat
I'm hungry like I gotta eat this animal
like what the [__] want to just go to
Whole Foods in sedan huh Sudan you
should try this juice cleanse yeah just
go man I gotta eat a rat
or the I'd rather watch two-time
commercials in a row yeah dude double
commercials bring back the Old Navy
break dancers
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you